okay let go over Showman's
again uh so you do not you do not it is
not a quadricep
exercise so it's not about how low you
go and it's not a sword cutting exercise
although it can concentrically be
such and it's definitely not a arm a
forearm or grrip strengthening or
shoulder strengthening any kind of arm
strengthening okay so we have to learn
how to do it internally so it's an
internal aspect drill okay and the first
part is really just a solo it's it's in
essence a solar drill in the sense that
I'm going to take the energy of my own
matter in conjunction with gravity
generates an energy and that energy I
ground Vector down in my midfoot okay
it's it's the same exact thing where
here he's pushing on me uh push push
push push and that that energy is on the
back foot that's on the back foot okay I
make that energy come down
okay
um when I do that my energy and your
energy go to the ground Vector okay well
here I don't have his energy I still
have my energy okay so I'm just working
on my energy got
it and I'm going
to uh have two Coq projection points
once I bring the sword into it and then
in the interim I have two iy adhesion
points on my grip into the sword okay so
the first poke you projection point is
when the sword comes down
boom and it's going to hit the left hand
left hand on down boom I'm going to
bounce the bookan off of that P CQ
projection and that's going to send the
tip up then I'm going to adhere to the
grip so I'm not bringing the sword up
the sword boom got bounced up and I'm
going here to the grip and at the top
you're going to have the other
projection point this time in the right
hand boom pop it'll go up boom it's
going to hit the right hand and then
it's going to come down and I have
another IG in my grip I am not pulling
it down I'm following the sword down and
boom left hand back up boom right hand
back down boom left hand okay
but your
mass has to be in that ground Vector so
that my energy of my materiality is
going down through me onto the ground
vector and just like if he has his hands
his energy now I go ahead and I take
that down so he's pushing you're pushing
back to knock me over knock me over
knock me
over so my energy and his energy he's
pushing push push push push push push
push push push push all that energy is
going down
I don't need a
base energy just like I I can do it on
one leg well of course I can do it on
two without a base
okay push push push push push grounding
now I'm not
[Music]
leaning
okay if you're not grounded when he
pushes you you will of course get push
because you need a bracing angle cuz
you're not ground voring the energy is
not passing through you you're stopping
it here at the hand so you need that
foot okay when the energy passes through
you you don't need that foot even to
project him off if I needed that foot
when I going to push him I'll push me
off cuz he has the BRAC angle and I
don't okay so our drill
is first get your weight on that midot
Vector then you do your palms and
they're trying to push you back and you
take his energy and you bring it onto
that midfoot Vector um let's be more
straight okay this
way again if he lets go I should not go
flying forward because my energy is just
going down he lets go and I don't fly
forward okay uh so we'll do that if
they're holding it and you're giving
good ample energy then let go and see
okay here we go
uh do not confuse stability with uh you
you being lower so I can have my my legs
locked you see and he's pushing and not
same thing I'm not going anywhere I keep
pushing as I move I can move you
see push push more straight because uh
dummy's watching it we go oh he's
pushing you down okay you want you want
to push against you you understand okay
so I can go down you might have to lower
yourself to keep the to keep the
downward angle I could go down you see
and it's still going it's going into
that same spot I could go up I can go on
one leg I can move I can
dance okay and you're not going to push
me over you got it so
don't don't go oh he's pushing me over
over let me lower my center it's not
it's not about your external
geometry okay it's about your internal
now there's a psychological component as
you try to not be knocked over that is
when your body will start to tense so
you're like don't let him knock me over
don't let me knock and then when he I'm
tense now and he releases that's when
you go
forward so as you're getting it
not only release your
body but release the mind and that
includes all the desires so he can let
go any time and I don't go fine forward
got it you you have to watch when you
start going ah Eureka Eureka he didn't
get me cuz you're probably tensing and
you can't feel it okay let try it
again so usually when you start out your
anxiety your your fear your dichotomous
mind your Will To Power you're going to
feel not at first CU when you first
start you're living like that but after
a while the first place you feel you can
recognize your tension is in your
shoulders okay but the uh what after you
can learn to reconcile that release that
you're going to find that the fear is
actually in my legs and then my lower
legs okay uh and that is really what has
to relax it you you're going to feel woo
oh yeah they're flexing and then you
have to release that so that the energy
goes all the way through you to the map
okay um
so we'll we'll up the energy right uh
and so as you up the energy the more uh
grounding the more I have to ground
because there's more energy to ground
okay so here it was him trying to push
me but once I go to displ you're going
to increase the energy and that is when
you as the energy increases that's when
you are going to feel whether oh yeah I
did feel for the flexion in my legs okay
so he's doing the first drill but at
some point I'm going to project him off
and you're going to see whether you're
tense or not cuz if you're tense you're
you'll bounce off the him he has he has
the supposed biomechanical
Advantage okay but I don't go flying off
okay so I have to release the lower legs
as much as
possible that means you're going to feel
them tense in all likelihood and then
you have to release you have to
consciously relax them like corpse pose
okay but you only have a speed of Life
fraction of a second to do it okay but
it will let you feel the tension at
least all right let's try
that all right as I'm watching
you you you are not yet understanding
midfoot vectoring okay it's midfoot
vectoring that that's the beginner
Gateway uh as you get going you could
you could Vector off anything you could
you could Vector off of of a inanimate
object like the chair that I've
demonstrated before right but the
beginner Gateway is the midfoot okay and
you have to watch your understanding of
uh good posture okay good posture is
midfoot vectoring why is it good because
it midfoot vectors okay uh there's no
good posture if it's not midfoot
vectoring so you don't want to go good
posture is straight posture no
straightness has nothing to do with
anything do you understand
that okay so some of you are too too up
too upright and if you pay attention
your weight is on your heels and in
order to keep yourself
erect you have to do little minute
flexion little fluttering flexion to
keep yourself in Balance so here here I
have my shoulders
back hips tucked under okay and the head
is flat and I am on the heels if I
release all tension in my lower legs and
the glutes you'll see that I fall
backwards okay so as you're trying for
this good posture that just arbitrarily
decided upon is good you're flexing a
lot of stuff and that's why the energy
can't go can't go through you okay so
stick to the reference point which is
midfoot vetrine okay and in order to get
midfoot vectoring all things being equal
in a horse dance you can't have your
chin up your Chin's going to be slightly
tucked because because as soon as you
bring your chin up that takes a lot of
weight behind the spine behind the
midfoot it's on my heels okay and then I
have to flex to keep myself upright so
I'm going to have my chin slightly
tucked my pelvis is not going to be with
this uh Western understanding of Samurai
posture because now I'm falling forward
and I'm using flexion to hold myself in
place okay on I relax my back and I
relax my glutes and legs and you'll see
it start to fall
forward so my back is not concave it's
going to be flat which is going to
require the pelvis to slightly tilt
under not a lot because now weights all
my heels and I can only stay upright
with this little minute fluttering uh
flexion so flat back slight pelvic tilt
very much like zazen
then my body same thing if I throw my
shoulders back because I want to be
Western military Dr guess what I have to
flex my lower legs to stay upright
because once I release them in the
glutes weight was actually to the back
and I'm shifting backwards
okay so there's more of a kind of
without collapsing the chest there's
just a kind of whever your shoulders
want to be normally well that's where my
shoulders go and you're going to see
there's a kind of more of a roundness to
my back as opposed to this shape to my
chest okay chin tucked pelvis under and
lastly if you pay attention the entire
torso from the head to uh the waist is
got a tiny can forward so I'm going to
keep the pelvic tuck I'm going to keep
the rounded back I'm going to keep the
chin tucked but I'm going to take my
torso head area and move it straight
back and you'll see I'm on my heels
again and it requires flexion in order
to stay in place you got that so you
have to have an Ever So slight in the
horse stance an Ever So slight C with
your torso keeping the head the chest
and back position the flat back and the
tuck pelvis and now I can release the
lower legs and in releasing the lower
legs my own energy goes straight down
into the M okay so let's go back to solo
and try that again